the 2017 hatred mail I'm sorry not
hatred mail this year coloring book
comic book themed calendar is available
at david pakman.com slash calendar 17
these are doing well first two days
we've we've got about twenty twenty-five
that have been sold the goal is 350 this
year last year we sold 201 calendars the
goal this year 350 and you can get the
calendar for free with your membership
at david pakman.com slash membership all
right i it's sort of a unique day for
hatred mail and i'll explain why in a
second brace yourselves for the only
information that can successfully
penetrate a tinfoil hats patriot man
written by patriots who hate david
pakman because america because freedom
so because time is limited before the
election and after the election of next
tuesday the election related hatred
males are basically going to be obsolete
and irrelevant i have a double dose for
you okay i think you're going to like
this to election-related hatred males
this week let's listen to the first one
tell this asked you to go Frick and
frack himself one trump has over hillary
he is a problem solver this Pakman is
not a problem solver but a problem
creator just jus Pakman is a little
[ __ ]
spineless shill what is this Pakman
dudes problem Pakman hmm what ethnicity
might that name be David Pakman is a
rapist disjointed unclear very strange I
think Rachel like that one is that what
you really seem to react to that one
yeah I really just kind of like the the
free association nature of it is it's
like a Rorschach test for hate reott ism
or something like that and then let's go
to the second of two election related
hate rate mails this is the last
election related hatred mail at least
pre-election right Pakman could care
less whether Trump is a racist bigoted
woman hater xenophobe
Trump is a threat to Jewish supremacy in
the US which goes against pac-man's
Jewish interests you guys honestly give
a damn whether a straight heterosexual
man uses the word [ __ ] you guys
honestly think Pakman cares whether
Trump calls many illegal Mexicans
rapists he could care less he's a Jew
that despises Trump and only cares about
the Jewish stranglehold in the US and
the rest of the Western world that's why
he supports Hillary despite how evil she
is because her masters are Jewish and
what's good for the Jews is good for
Pakman use your heads you dumb ass
Hillary drones unbelievable stupid
people like this exist twice I could
care less which of course means that you
do care people die that is I will never
get how people since fifth grade when
someone says I could care less about
that oh so you do care and clearly it we
weren't going to get that right from
these hatreds and all just a lot of
focus on me being Jewish and Hillary and
Trump and I this isn't going to stop
after the election is it yeah and I love
this idea that because you're a straight
white male you can't have any sort of
empathy for other noble right yeah you
can only care for minority groups if
you're part of that minority group
that's we've learned that many many
times
so listen fight back against the hate
reott some people call this hate reott
repellent this is the 2017 david pakman
show calendar which you can get for free
with a membership at david pakman.com
slash calendar 17